[Music]
you've never faced anything like this
let them come
there is a cinematic quality to go to
music it's a pretty epic score this
movie being set in 1994 allowed us to
establish a different sound
that reflected the environments and the
cultures of the characters Stephen
wanted to do something very special so
he asked Toby and nuege who plays reek
in our film for Toby to actually do a
song
it all came together in a masterful
collaboration seeing him live in
performance I was like how can we
capture that energy and the Transformers
film the real large Grill ain't nobody
out here hard to kill it again from
front to back
it was really a phenomenal opportunity I
just couldn't believe it it was a great
pleasure to have both not only Steven
but also Toby in the studio here with us
to really hear what we did I can't wait
for people to check it out
baby
Transformers rise of the beasts